Well it's official now.
Cambridge has released a new video
explaining what are the benefits and advantages
of the new platform.
It's not gonna change much honestly.
Basically what they're doing
is trying to push their digital platform.
They will still have the paper based exams again.
Do not be confused.
You will not be able to take the exam from your house.
You have to go to an exam center.
In the video
they explain the user friendly interface.
The computer
version of the exam has always been available.
The thing is that now
the results will be available up to 5 days
after you take the exam.
Now you can register up to 2 working days
before the exam
and it's gonna be on demand.
That means that
the exam will be available pretty much anytime.
Basically these changes will happen
just in the background.
And if you did know,
the benefits are that in the listening section
you will wear headphones.
That keeps you in control of how
high you want the volume.
Another thing is the writing
because it has a lot of advantages.
It has work out,
you can edit the work,
you can copy paste from within the same window.
You will not be able to access the internet
or anything like that
in the reading section.
People complain said they will not be able to underline
or make annotations
body in the digital format.
You've always been able to highlight
and you can Add all your notes.
All the notes that you want.
Pretty much the same as in the paper version.
Now the speaking will be basically the same
and there will not be any changes.
The only changes is that
all the visuals will be seen on a screen.
You will not take papers with you and.
And Cambridge will make sure that the
tasks are not repeated
because they will automatically update.
And the examiners will not
put your marks in a Mark sheet.
The marks will be directly uploaded
through an app,
a special app for examiners,
to the Cambridge website
so results are immediately in their database.
Remember that
you can visit the website that you see on the screen.
If you want more information about the digital format,
don't hesitate to call them
and ask them for more information about
the new digital system.